[Music]
So when you're mounted concepts,
uh the first concept is just how to det
him. So he's got a four-point stance now
with between his hands and legs. Okay.
So, we want to take away two legs of the
table and then take his balance that
way. So, we'll just start in this admin
mount here. And uh we're going to come
let's come under. So, we'll come under
two hands. Bump his hand with your
shoulder. Pull it on down.
Transition tricep and forearm. Trap the
same side leg. And then bridge his head
over your head.
come up and we'll already go right into
the um closed guard escapes. So check
the leg cross out into the for
all right let's try okay again from the
admin mount the variation is I'll come
through this time
and that over hook trap that arm. Trap
that same side leg for this one. Make
sure that you're going to turn your palm
up. Maybe even hug the guy's shoulder
just so you don't get your hand broken.
And then if necessary, you can use this
on the hip to push here. But you should
probably keep that guard hand up. I come
up.
I do the same thing. Come up out the
same way and into the force option.
Okay, try me. This time we're going to
have him just sitting up. Okay. And we
want to know how to get to that first
concept where he's got a hand on the
mat. Okay. That's the one we're going to
attack. So on this one, I'm gonna do
several things at once. I can grab up
and pull him so his hands get on the
mat. I'm going to knee bump him so his
hands get on the mat. And I'm going to
bridge so his hands get on the mat. So I
kind of do all that at once.
I'm going to push myself up with my
legs.
I can go here
or here. Either one doesn't matter. And
then
the traps the same, the escapees the
same, and the force option is the same.
Saying it's seated up. Boom.
All right, let's try. Really, for me, I
need to have my feet near my glutes, my
elbows anchored, kind of like I'm in
that boxing stance. My elbows will stop
him from doing a high mount. Okay, but
sometimes it happens.
It's much harder. If I bridge here, I
won't affect him at all. I can't reach
it with my knee. So, we're just going to
push him down my stomach with my two
hands here. And now you're right back
where you start.
Got the high mount. None of that works.
Take your two hands, push the center
down,
you're out. Use that concept of
deposting the one hand, attacking both
sides of the table um
more broadly. Okay. So often times when
people are trying to secure their mouth,
they'll go ahead and hook on their on
your head. Okay? And you're like, I
can't get him off because he's hooking
on my head. But this arm is trapped. So
we're going to come around,
hug the side of my head, the back of my
head. I do the same thing. I can use
this other hand on his hip or his
shoulder. And I start doing the same
exact thing. And I'm out.
See his own arm when he's hooking me
around. Trap.
Trap. Same size foot. Bridge.
Push. He's open. Out. Course off. He's
securing his mount even more. So, he has
the arm control here and he has a great
vine cuz he's going to hook my knees.
Okay. And so, I can't get what I need to
get going. Okay. So, we'll unhook the
grape vine. All I'm going to do is
extend one leg,
push him down, and now come inside. And
then I'm working
that same mountain reverse
again. Escaping
the grape vines.
He's got it. He's really trying to
stretch me out. I just come up inside.
I'm free.
and working the same amount. All right.
So,
he's got this neck tie. Okay.
Whether he's grave binding or not,
doesn't matter. We already know how to
free it and we know how to trap. Okay.
Doesn't matter. So, we're out.
Boom. He's holding me really tight with
that. Okay. And here's where I just
start punching. Okay. So, I punch and I
punch and I punch and then you're out.
Okay. And you have that. Uh, put a
kicking shield right here and No, cuz
I'm going to punch at him and I don't
want to hit James in the face.
Right here. And put another kicking
shield over here.
Got it. Cuz James thought he could hold
on, right?
This is This is what I'm feeling. Okay,
people. Let go. You got it. All right,
try it again. So, like that last one, he
occupied one post that I'm going to
attack on that side. So, they do that a
lot. Okay. So, let's say he's like just
holding my hands on on my chest. Well,
this arm is not currently posting. So I
can still
attack that side. And I'm out.
He's trapping me here. If you if you
can, you can kind of elbow trap and
wrist trap here. But a lot of times they
get so occupied with just holding you
down
that you're often running, okay, into
the force. So he's occupied his hand
trying to control my Let's say he's
down. Okay. down and he's all based out
here. So, there's no point trying trying
it. Okay, I'm not going to be strong
enough here to get that. But, let's say
he goes up to uh try to punch. So, he's
going to go up to try to drive that
punch in. Okay. So, as he goes up again,
that hand is now not posting. Okay. So,
he's occupying the hand again. So, as he
goes up, he comes down. I pass it over
like this. And I'm going to do something
a little different now. Okay. I'm just
going to push in that way.
As he tries to come back,
that's where I can get it.
And he's going up. He punches. I move it
over. Let him come around and I trap.
And I'm on that side. Boom. Up and up.
So, there's any number of reasons why I
can get this arm on the other side. We
just had one example. He came to punch
and I moved it over.
And what I'm going to do is keep that
over there. So, there's a lot of
structural integrity here. I'll move
myself up and come up and start seeking
height. Don't give up. So, you Okay.
post and my weight is is on his head.
Okay. So, try to come back. He's got the
structural integrity of my right hand on
the mat to deal with. Okay. Plus, my
torso here. So, I'll take that arm away.
Try to come back to your left. Okay.
And I don't want him standing up. So, I
have my weight on his head. Try to come
up. And I want him to start to lift me
when he's trying to come up like that.
Okay. And my hips are now off the ground
between this.
You can of course come out from here.
You can come out and take the back from
here.
Either one.
So we did it off the punch. Boom. Up. I
got to get my center out. start seeking
height. Keep my head above his head.
He's trying to lift up. That's what I
like to use to get my hips up and then
you out. Whichever way you want to go
back into force option. Okay. All right.
Whichever technique you're using, he
gets the closed guard. And we already
know bicep ties, pull, push, and you're
out. We use our clo our closed guard.
He gets the guard biceps
up. Push and out. Last one.
When I'm coming out and I go for the
back, we're here and come in. I'll push
him forward
and keep the arm control here. Okay. If
you want, you can dismount
and go to force option down here. And
you're trying not to have all this
stuff. He's going to try not to let me
depose. Okay.
His hands. Um, so he defends. Okay. And
again in his defense, the arm is
deposed. Okay. So let's say he's even
low with weight on me. Okay. And same
thing, I'm going here. He defends and
I'm just going to keep it tight on him.
And I do the same thing. And I'm off and
go.
It doesn't matter which way he goes to
defend. I keep it off the ground. Boom.
Boom. And we're off and going.
So, just because you don't succeed,
he deeposted his hand. Okay. In one
case, I was able to grab it, but in
another case, let's say he's making
multiple circles. I'm just keeping it
off the ground. And in that time,
I'm prepping the foot and going.
Okay. So, we'll do that one.
So, in my attempt to get whatever and my
backup against his defense that I'm
trying to keep it off the mat, he's
trying to get it back on the mat. I can
start to take his balance. You see, even
as even though it's occupied. So, let's
say I'm taking his balance. He gets it
off and back on the mat. You see? Well,
it's back on the mat
and the knee gets light. If I can, I'll
go to the octopus.
If I can't, I go to elbow knee. Okay?
I'm doing the same thing. If he's
overpowering me,
then I'll take the sweep. Okay. What I'm
looking for
is
this light knee, which happens as he's
trying to defend the deposting of this
hand or whatever arm you're doing. One
of the knees will get light. That's
where I'll do elbow D or octopus. Okay.
So, I'm trying my thing. Boom. You can
see it's light.
There it is. Right there. He comes back.
I can go to elbow, knee, and into the
sweep.
He keeps his balance. And I'm just in
the guard. And then my guard techniques
are from here that we already have. So I
find the gift wrap cuz he cross body.
I have them out. From here I have the
option to demount and go to force
option. Keep it turn
back mount or dismount and go to force
option. Okay. I'm looking for those
light knees.
And I'm playing mount reversal
with elbow knee and the octopus. So same
thing. Boom. There's that. The knee is
light. Push. He comes back. He's too
strong. I go to elbow knee. Then my
guard escapes
back up.
Pushing it. Boom.
I'm running the octopus.
Same thing. He overpowers.
Take the sweep
mount force options. Play with it.
Okay. So, some people like hug hug hug.
Okay. Again, he's hugging high,
right? And you go here. I can't. The
knee is light, but I can't do anything
about it. So, you have to go back. You
push him down and you don't let him come
back up. So, as you're trying all of
this stuff, there's that. And then I
have to use angle of deflection
with angle deviation. Same thing. Let's
say we're going here. He's tries for the
grape vine. I unhook it and you're out.
Okay. Same exact thing. Boom. Send
weight forward.
Then the arm that is pinned, which in
this case is the left arm, that's the
side I go out on. So he can't grab me as
I'm getting up.